[Music]
we are Jeff Anita Fisher we're from
Kidron Ohio
[Music]
I am a heating and cooling installer and
I'm a CPA I mean I grew up in a poor
environment and my memory when we first
got married was wow we have so much
money we didn't really have a plan now
we didn't have a plan I think we need to
pay the bills I came in and that was it
the majority of our depth was credit
card loans vehicle loans we owed some
money to a friend a personal loan
medical and more kids came a little hole
along and you know everything that goes
into having kids and those five years
really was the build up of debt we
purchased a bed and the bed went on
credit card that month I could not pay
the full balance that seemed to be the
turning point of credit card balances
and having to make payments and not
paying it off monthly and so I would say
at that point is where our debt free
journey began
we weren't really on the Dave Ramsey
plan yet but we started doing a budget
we started looking at what our monthly
expenses would be in what our monthly
income is going to be it didn't get
refined I would say until we started the
Dave Ramsey plan somebody I think it was
a client of mine actually introduced me
to - Dave Ramsey I we did a lease on one
of our vehicles and that's when she said
well you need to read this book and so
she had given me the book to read I
brought it home and read and I'm like oh
my word this is us all the way this is
us
I'd listen online at work when he was on
in the afternoons and I started hearing
all these people do their debt-free
scream and it would almost make me tear
up with how ecstatic they were I would
say probably a year from when I first
started talking about it after I've been
listening to where he actually said fine
we have to do something just do it so
yeah we were on a family reunion and our
family were they were going to an
authentic German
home for a German meal and we didn't
have the money to buy the tickets to go
to that and my aunt came forward and a
lot our tickets for that and that was
that was kind of embarrassing moment for
me and I think that was the turning
point for us or for me that said yeah
you know I think we could do the Dave
Ramsey class and I think I saw a big
smile on my wife's basement okay so once
we got started on the debt snowball I
just was like trying to make a
bare-bones budget so that we could put
more towards this debt so he would have
to pull me back sometimes when we would
look at the budget and I went in about
groceries yeah yeah we do need to buy
groceries so maybe we should put a
little bit less towards the debt
snowball so it couldn't go fast enough
for me says the debt snowball in the
first couple we knocked out pretty
quickly I think I mean we knocked three
or four right off the list with happy
month I think we knew that like within
that last six months that it would be at
a certain time frame then we should be
out of debt that's the thing the other
band was on the list and it had been
paid off just a short walk short of I
mean we paid off in June maybe and so it
was totaled in September so we were able
to pay cash yeah we paid cash for our
next week that's an exhilarating feeling
here to walk into a car dealership we
literally paid cash and you can get a
better price when you think you put off
a lot of maintenance things on the house
so we put off putting a new roof on we
put a new roof on since we've been out
again you know that's a $5,000 thing
that when we cash flow I mean we have
been able to budget in
all of our kids things that they need
and not not have to go into debt
I think we've changed our kids future
we've changed know what what that looks
like for them I remember sitting in the
family room watching TV and Anita came
in and said if Christmas wasn't in
December we would we could have a job I
mean it was almost the exact amount that
I would have budgeted for Christmas was
almost the exact amount of that last
discover payment I think I was watching
TV with Natalie I think she was on line
ID she was sitting there maybe doing
homework or something and she just said
well why don't we just push off
Christmas and we're like what what do
you what do you mean she's a wall we
just have Christmas next one and I know
a couple of times we said are you sure
you want to do this or you really want
to I mean do you know what this means
her mom even questioned it you know
really you're not having Christmas but
you can we buy Christmas present for a
while yeah you can but we're just not we
thought was amazing that you know our
daughter would even acknowledge that
[Music]
after being reluctant to join the Dave
Ramsey FPU class we work for 39 months
to successfully pay off 62 thousand
dollars in debt and living a cash-flow
life it was a difficult journey it's
still a journey that we're on and
continue to work on but we have
definitely changed our kids lives and
they will hopefully benefit from that in
the future
where
[Music]
[Music]